so imagine the game that you love being
filled with people
trying to steal from you every single
day
you log in and there they are constantly
scamming people
and the developer of the game has done
absolutely nothing
to try to stop it things have gotten so
bad that you've decided to take matters
into your own hands
by calling these people out across
multiple youtube videos
you've posted to your own channel but
now
because you've decided to speak out
those same scammers
are threatening your life
alright guys we have a youtube channel
and you should subscribe to it
why well for one it helps us figure out
what stories you want to see
more of and then it helps us track them
down reason number two
well there is no reason number two just
subscribe already
recently runescape youtuber kemp q
decided to investigate
two pretty popular but shady aspects of
the game
the dual arena and what's referred to as
staking
this place has festered one of the most
toxic communities in online gaming
and because he decided to expose this
connected group of scammers
chem q is now getting death threats
we'll dive into his story in just a
second but first
i gotta give you some context now the
dual arena is exactly what it sounds
like it's an arena in the middle of the
desert where players go to fight each
other and staking is where players
gamble or stake their gold
in the dual arena the gambling aspect of
staking comes in
because typically both players agree to
fight by the same set of rules while
using the same basic
weapons essentially turning what's
normally a skill based
fight into a coin flip i ever understand
i need a tank here oh i lose
give me one tanker right now i lost
even if i expect i can't hit a 57 bro he
had double 25s
now according to camp q the dual arena
was originally meant as a place where
players could host
friendly duels without putting any crazy
money on the line but the problem is
the dual arena has been literally
overrun
with people trying to scam players out
of their gold i
as this is most easily observed at the
dual arena where there would usually be
a lot of people advertising for
fun stakes you know just like you don't
stake any money or anything you just do
friendly duels with your friends
where that happens has happened less and
less over the years
and now that doesn't happen at all all
of the dual
the entirety of the dual arena right now
is simply just people that are trying to
manipulate others to
make profit for themselves it's very
clear to even
a lay flay viewer that the dual arena is
just
completely for people to make money from
from
innocent players there are a ton of
different scams happening within the
dual arena hell
we can make a standalone video going
over all of them
you've got players ddosing servers
you've got players pulling a fast one
and subtly changing the rules of a duel
so they can get an advantage
the list goes on this guy is attempting
the old switch the combat style trick
one of the more common scams and most of
these scams in one way or another
are related to a concept called real
world trading
now this part is kind of complicated so
just
stick with me see runescape has this
market economy where gold which is the
currency of the game
has actual real world value much like
any market the real world price of gold
fluctuates based on a bunch of different
factors
so because you can buy and sell gold
from these shady third-party websites
scammers are doing
everything they can to hijack your gold
and then turning around and selling it
for an actual
profit and just to be crystal [ __ ]
clear here i said it in our autoblock
video and i'll say it again
real world trading is not allowed it is
against developer jagex's rules and your
account will be banned if you're caught
so gambling was essentially taken out of
runescape
or was it there's one exception the dual
arena and with the ability to sell
in-game gp for real-world currency
players will do anything to take your
money from you but these are the reasons
why
real world trade needs to be against the
rules because a small part of the player
base doesn't see this as a game
they see it as a way to make real life
money alright so let's just recap where
we are so far
we have an almost 20 year old game that
millions of people love to play
but in one very specific part of it it's
a complete
mess now you might be wondering at this
point why jagex hasn't tried to fix this
problem
or gotten rid of the dual arena entirely
see the thing
is there's a bit of a civil war
happening in runescape
with the community divided on a ton of
issues
one of which happens to be the dual
arena and how it's used to exploit
people and despite the fact that a lot
of people see it as a giant
problem just as many people still
seemingly enjoy it and while jagex says
they have plans to tweak the dual arena
its continued popularity is why they
haven't gotten rid of it entirely
this is something asthma gold talked to
a jagex developer about in a recent
interview
so what we're seeing at the moment is
quite a vocal message from the community
which is
we want to see you kind of dismantle the
arena
or tackle types of content around the
dueling arena
to mitigate the the really negative
types of communities around it
okay but let's get back to kemp q he's
been playing runescape for 14 years and
he's been talking about these issues for
a long ass time now
so pretty quickly after publishing his
investigation in early november
kemp q started getting death threats
from people who literally make their
living off of scamming people in the
dual arena
in old school runescape and let me tell
you
some of these threats are [ __ ] wild
they threatened to swat him
to torpedo his house if he didn't take
down the videos
and there were some truly alarming
messages about hiring
hitmen to come kill him all the while
kepq is trolling these scammers by
offering to take down his videos if they
donate
50 grand to a charity gofundme now
clearly
he rattled these people with the three
videos that he put out which
got me wondering why what's at stake for
these scammers
the answer is as runescape youtuber crum
points out
a potential ton of money you know
there's many businesses
in the runescape black market that are
netting in the high
six figures and low seven figure ranges
and these gold sites were no exception
to that in fact they were on the very
high end
we're talking about million dollar
businesses and according to kemp q
this isn't just a few joe shmoe morons
threatening kids
it's a connected group of people who all
know each other who all
scam people through real world trading
and who as we've seen
will try to destroy you if you talk
about them there's a highly
organized criminal ring revolving around
the dual arena and they have
their hands in lots of different boxes
pockets and they're able to
get information about people on the
internet and they they have a lot of
they probably hire um you know personal
investigators to
research people and try to get their
information so that they can either
dox them or threaten them with something
and just to drive this point home even
further
kemp q is not the first person to try to
expose what the hell is going on in the
dual arena
according to him four other runescape
youtubers have made videos trying to
expose this problem
only to pull them down later once they
experience death threats and harassment
of their own
something that really surprised me when
i started looking into this more deeply
was the fact that four other content
creators on youtube
had already been threatened their lives
have been threatened their livelihoods
their facebook accounts have been
compromised bomb threats have been
called in
that's the thing that most surprised me
about this is that other people have
already tried to cover this story
but i'm the only one that's you know
kind of still standing
because all the other videos have been
taken down because the people that are
scamming at the dual arena
have kind of bullied these other content
creators into submission
but instead of pulling his videos down
and keeping quiet
kemp q tried a different tactic and
actually doubled down
he's made two videos about the death
threats and harassment he's gotten
the thinking being that if i continue to
call these dudes out
they'll have nowhere left to hide i
should have realized by now i don't care
that they're making money from this game
i care that they're being malevolent and
manipulative while they do it and their
toxicity needs to be cleaved out from a
community that i've been a part of for
14 years
they don't care about any of us they
just want their money and will do
anything to get it it's pretty crazy to
me
that four different youtubers can be
bullied into silence
and another one can be actively
receiving death threats
and the developer jagex does not see an
immediate need to address the dual arena
as a problem
don't get me wrong it's pretty cool that
runescape is this deep
and offers hours and hours and hours of
content
but honestly you have to ask the
question what is the popularity of that
content
worth if people's lives are being put at
risk
because of it devin i actually actually
have some breaking news for you that i
think you may not have okay
all right breaking news the makers of
hitman
oh [ __ ] iowa interactive okay their next
project
is a double
that is so [ __ ] cool i know that
you're a huge hitman
stan yes and i know that you love
james bond so listen honestly you take
you take hitman changing disguises
having to like go to cool parties and
like
make sure you don't get noticed and then
you add in all of
i'll them that one more time i just need
some
liquids here who wants coffee i just
made a fresh pot of coffee does anybody
want coffee